this could have been avoided if you
hadn't played for something you don't
understand I'm sorry
it is funny it's you don't get why we
need Tony maybe this might not be the
time really that's it
you just roll over show your belly every
time somebody snarls only when I've
created a murder bot we didn't we
weren't even close were we close to an
interface well you did something right
and you did it right here The Avengers
were supposed to be different than she
anybody remember when I carried a nuke
through a wormhole no it's never come
save New York never heard that
recall that a hostile alien army came
charging through a hole in space we're
staying at 300 feet below it were the
Avengers we can bust arms dealers all
the live long day but that up there
that's that's the endgame how are you
guys planning on beating them together
Scott I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption do you
absolutely my days of breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over
what do you want me to do I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
make sense
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Marvel
just posted a clip that does a really
good job of explaining the connection
between Avengers age of Ultron ant-man
in Captain America Civil War now
remember ant-man is part of phase 2 it's
like the very end of phase 2 and Captain
America Civil War is the beginning of
phase 3 so I'll play the clip right now
and then I'll explain what it means
next week on news front will discuss the
fallout from the most recent Avengers
conflicts in sokovia and the ongoing aid
efforts in that region also we'll
revisit a story from a few years ago in
the case of former Vista Corp employee
and cyber criminals Scott Lang who's set
to be released from federal prison on
July 17 be sure to follow us online for
those stories and more so in case you
forgot that's leslie bibb from the Iron
Man movies she plays the reporter that
Tony Stark sleeps with and Pepperpot
shades amita's is mostly used for comedy
but she's a news reporter in the Marvel
Universe
so of course she's gonna report on the
Avengers trashing sokovia and their
fight with Ultron Marvel has used that
device of having news reporters tie all
the things that are going on in their
big events together like Ben Urich he's
a news reporter in daredevil but in the
larger Marvel context in the comics
during civil war he reported on what was
going on between the government and the
heroes her news report is a couple
different stories though it's not like
she's trying to tie Scott Lang to
sokovia he says that her news network is
having her report on all these big
things going on in the Marvel Universe
so she's doing the job of Ben Urich you
know although if you're like a comic
book purist you would rather see Ben
Urich do it everybody be careful not to
post spoilers about what happens to him
in daredevil just I'm sure there are a
couple people that might not have seen
that yet I like the way they spin this
she's a little bit more neutral like I
mean she comes off as a little more
caddy and the Iron Man films but you can
see how Marvel might use pundits that to
try and spin what the Avengers are doing
in bad ways you know just like slant the
news either right or left so don't be
surprised if when Civil War comes along
they use people like Rush Limbaugh to
hype up the news and in spin it certain
ways a man is like the last book end of
phase 2
technically Avengers age of Ultron was
the end of phase 2 but really ant-man is
the bookend to that it's really the job
of this film to show you that anybody
including ex-cons can be big heroes like
the Avengers the way I'm thinking about
ant-man right now
in the context of the Avengers is that
when we get to Captain America's Civil
War he'll be like the guy to let the air
out of the balloon before it pops just
because the tension will be so crazy
between Captain America and Iron Man but
I like the way the clip tells you he's
not just an ex-con he is an engineer
like he has a very advanced degree he's
very smart person he's not just a common
thief
so like the film will explain that so if
you read the comics he's not like the
Eric O'Grady ant-man he's not
irredeemable ant-man
maybe a little morally grave but really
it's his relationship with his daughter
that'll explain where he's coming from
I know a lot of you guys been asking for
a wasp video like a Janet Van Dyne video
so I'll do that next for ant-man but
I've got a couple other videos so that
might not post till this weekend I've
just I've got like a couple of Comic Con
videos that I'm gonna start rolling out
in the next couple days just to remind
you guys Marvel isn't taking any movies
to comic-con it's just because they
really don't have anything to promote
they've already done all the marketing
that they're gonna do for ant-man so
it's not like they need to hype it up
anymore and new brand of the Marvel
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm gonna be
posting my spider-man villain video Nick
so I just I'll remind everyone when I
post that Kevin Feige did imply that
they're bringing Captain America Civil
War footage to d23 later this summer so
I think that's when the first trailer is
gonna drop officially we're still not
quite within six months of Captain
America's Civil War coming out that's
gonna be next spring but usually Marvel
drops the first trailer when we get
within like a year window and we're well
within that let me know you think though
do you like the idea of Marvel using the
news like literally using the news to
tie together all their films you had
like those dream sequences that Thor had
during Avengers age of Ultron where he
sees visions of infinity war that kind
of type things together in more ethereal
ways and then you have more real-world
stuff going on where the news is like
hey the Avengers just trashed the
out of this small country when are we
gonna hold them accountable for this
that speaks to a lot of what the
government is gonna be doing in Captain
America's Civil War like finding a way
to keep heroes accountable so start
looking for those Comic Con videos that
I'll be posting tomorrow and in don't
worry just because there's not gonna be
a lot of like Marvel movie stuff going
on at Comic Con I'll still do a Marvel
giveaway that week while you wait for
that you can click here to learn all
about Hank Pimm's history in the comics
and you can click here to learn about
what's going on with spider-man and
Captain America Civil War
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you